javanese determination to hunt whales
has seen them travel as far south as
Antarctica they were exploiting a
loophole in international rules which
permitted whaling for scientific
research even though the whale meat was
eaten but the Japanese government has
long tried to convince the International
Whaling Commission to lift its ban on
commercial hunting I mean failed to do
so it's decided to quit the organization
that day no quota we have sorts
resolutions a regime sustainable
commercial whaling for over 30 years
however there was no concession made
from the countries which only focus on
whale conservation regrettably we have
reached a decision that it's impossible
IWC
seek the coexistence of states with
different views Environment Secretary
Michael Gove criticized the decision
saying the UK is strongly opposed to
commercial whaling and will continue to
fight for the protection and welfare of
these majestic mammals Japan joins
Norway and Iceland which had really
decided to ignore the IWC
in order to set its own rules and how
many whales could be killed the minke
whale is the most commonly hunted but
fin and say whales are also taken the
Japanese have a quoted a hunt 503 minke
whales a year and take at least that
number that compares to the Norwegians
who permit up to one thousand two
hundred and seventy eight but actually
killed 454 this year and the Icelanders
who have a quote of two hundred and
sixty two but only hunted six the
increasing popularity of whale watching
has provided an alternative source of
revenue conservation groups have accused
the Japanese of becoming a pirate nation
by abandoning international rules
it's a snub to the international
community when the UN requires that
countries cooperate to manage marine
resources most of the world wants to use
whales in a humane sustainable way and
that's whale watching in the 21st
century and that can't happen
sustainably in the long term if some
countries go off and carry on killing
them in awful inhumane ways the Japanese
government says in future whalers will
stick to their own territorial waters
teen in the Southern Ocean had led to
violent clashes with conservationists
the sea Shepherd organization actually
welcomed the Japanese decision as it
ends the pretense of hunting for
research I think it's a very positive
development what this means is there
will be no whaling in the Southern Ocean
Whale Sanctuary it means that the IWC
will be able to pass motion to establish
the South Atlantic whale sanctuary it
ends whaling in the southern hemisphere
and that is a good thing
the Japanese have always argued that
there is an appetite in the country for
eating whale though there's been a huge
decline in how much is consumed in woods
Sky News